hurricane Irma has forced millions of
people to leave their homes Florida
Governor Rick Scott urged everyone in
the Florida Keys to get out many in
Miami and the rest of South Florida are
also evacuating but not everyone is
heating the warning Carter Evans is in
Jupiter Florida Carter good morning good
morning you know this is a pretty common
sight around the area windows and doors
boarded up tight I'll tell you most
people around here who've been told to
evacuate are long gone but we still have
found many people even in mandatory
evacuation zones who say they aren't
going anywhere
as thousands of Floridians rushed to
safety ahead of the storm they're
running into heavy traffic and long
lines for gas if you don't have things
in order but some like store clerk
Joshua Scott near Lake Okeechobee are
refusing to leave Miami so it's like if
I go the Army Corps of Engineers is
pumping water out of nearby canals ahead
of the storm but emergency managers are
concerned about the dike around the lake
it's still not enough to force Mike Cobb
do with a QA there's nothing to be
afraid of you've been living on his dock
your whole life run what's the beer
freighter in Miami Dade County more than
650,000 people were ordered to leave
their homes the largest evacuation in
the county's history all 79 thousand
residents in Monroe County which
includes the Florida Keys are also under
evacuation Miami residents Debbie and
Daisy Lopez also decided to ride out the
storm at home well how long we been
through already back near Lake
Okeechobee even though the situation
seems dire Joshua Scott is optimistic it
gets to the point where you've just got
to pretend like you know it's not gonna
happen but if it does you just what are
you gonna go about it
you know I'll tell you they boarded this
stuff up really tight too and here's why
because we're gonna be exposed to the
dirty side of the storm that's the upper
white right quadrant that's supposed to
be the windiest part so they're
expecting some significant problems here
that could also potentially spawn
tornadoes and of course that significant
storm surge Anthony Carter Evans in
Jupiter Florida Thank You Carter
you know I it's it's it scares me when
people don't heed these warnings when
the governor is begging you to go you
know it's probably time to go people
have seen the other storms and maybe it
hasn't been as bad as they thought I
think that's where people sometimes
forget each storm is talking something
that's that's lick within a few miles an
hour of a category 5